les images qui nous arrive de butch a
depuis deux jours rappellent les pires
massacres
la ville de 37 mille habitants a été
lourdement bombardée pendant 30 jours
puis occupé par les forces russes qui
semble s'être défoulé sur des civils
innocents
cette résidente à chercher son mari
pendant 13 jours elle l'a trouvé
sommairement enterré dans le sous-sol
d'un bâtiment rien y prier chez eux
on lui a tiré une balle dans la tête
ajoute elle son visage a été mutilée il
a été torturé gelé reconnu grâce à ces
chaussures et à son pantalon
c'est très clair lorsqu'on tombe sur un
corps par exemple qui a les mains
attachées derrière le dos et qui a eu
sa part à une exécution sommaire ces
images fournies par la présidence
ukrainienne montre volodymyr et lenski
accueilli en héros à bout de chat par
ses habitants qui reçoivent de l'aide
alimentaire
ce sont des crimes de guerre dit il qui
seront reconnus par le match comme un
génocide une accusation aussitôt réfutée
par les russes qui dénoncent une mise en
scène
nos militaires dit il avait déjà quitté
la ville le 31 mars ils marchent debout
tchane arrière à porter tel ce jour là
mais deux jours plus tard on voit cette
mise en scène dans les rues or ces
images c'est elle est analysée par le
new york times révèle que des corps
jonchaient déjà les rues de boutiques il
y a trois semaines ce que confirme human
right watch abuja le corps bien
documents et on a pu continuer donc
quatre exécutions sommaires lé 4 mars
par les forces russes des très clair on
voit énormément d'incidents qui est
s'apparente très fortement les crimes de
guerre ils ont ce québécois était en
ukraine pendant les deux premières
semaines du conflit pour parler à des
témoins de ces atrocités human right
watch rapporte des viols et des
exécutions sommaires aussi à kharkiv qui
oeuvrent tchernihiv fait ce travail
parce qu'on cherche a rappelé à toutes
les parties au conflit dans quelques
conflits que ce soit que la guerre doit
se faire à l'intérieur de l'oeil qui ont
été universellement acceptées depuis
pratiquement un siècle depuis
les alliés de l'otan dénonce vivement
les massacres de boot ya les scènes sont
insoutenables ce qui vient de se passer
à butch impose un nouveau train de
sanctions et des mesures très claires la
ministre mélanie joly dit que le canada
va donner plus de moyens au tribunal
pénal international pour enquêter sur
ces allégations de crimes de guerre
parce que c'est complètement
inacceptable si chacun c'est inhumain ce
qui se passe présentement en ukraine
cet homme est brutale du tube hayden ce
qui se passe à butcher est scandaleux
mais ce n'est pas un génocide les
américains et les européens rejettent
toujours l'appel des ukrainiens pour un
soutien plus direct sur le terrain qu
abou thiam n'est pas un cas isolé ça
fausse le jeu se fâche veut c'est du
fascisme pur dit cet homme qui vient de
découvrir les corps de trois membres de
sa famille partiellement enterrée dans
les bois il veut nous détruire juste
parce que nous sommes ukrainien
[Musique]
j'ai un message aux européens et dit il
regardez ça si vous ne voulez pas que
cela arrive dans vos forêts il faut nous
aider plus efficacement
ici se fit langlois radio canada
montréal